bonjour d'amiante et rédacteur en chef
de la gazette de saint quentin en
yvelines mais déjà une question un peu
personnel comment est ce que vous vivez
le confinement autant qu'ils viennois
bas pour l'instant ce jusque là sarah
donc on peut continuer à faire des
courses et travaille un peu chez soi ça
va c'est pour moi beaucoup moins de
monde possible tu aimes ça c'est quand
même un métier où on va vers les autres
donc d'être chez soi ça doit changer pas
mal le quotidien
ça change totalement c'est clair que là
on a eu 100 fois moins de personnes que
quand on travaille habituellement
là on est un peu au début on est au
début du confinement donc ça va mais je
pense que les reportages vont très vite
me manquer non justement comment s'est
adapté votre rédaction
est ce que vous allez décrire le
quotidien d'un journaliste à la maison
alors nous pensent tant que savoir qu'on
a suspendu depuis
depuis ce mardi 17 la publication de la
gazette de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
nous on avait pris des mesures déjà
entre guillemets de mise en quarantaine
des la semaine précédent on a vu par
exemple on n'a finalement pas couverts
les annonces des résultats des élections
au sipal en mairie il a touché depuis le
bureau depuis chez nous et puis donc là
nous on travaille pub pour la cadette de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines actuellement
l'éducation a suspendu en papier comme
ce que j'aimerais c'est à dire que
jusqu'à ce que le confinant général soit
annoncée ont travaillé par téléphone par
téléphone beaucoup de vent beaucoup de
l'action des réseaux sociaux on
surveille les boîtes mail ouais c'est de
surveiller un petit peu de tout ce qui
se passe de sur les réseaux sociaux et
puis pas mal de téléphones sont restés
alors quelle est la suite pour votre
journal comment les gens vont pouvoir
lire des articles de veau aux
journalistes alors pour donc c'est
valable pour l'accuser de saint quentin
en yvelines et la gazette en yvelines
bon les deux publications ont été
stoppés mais tous les journalistes
travaillent pour le site web tiers 78
tous là on est en temps réel en temps
réel donc tous les jours on publie des
articles d'actualité chaude aussi tenir
là les événements en a
ce qui peut se passer autour de chez eux
donc on pense évidemment presque tous
les articles sont alliés aux navires y
merci beaucoup et damien la boue